new efforts to help minimize the
homeless problem here in the valley
today catholic charities gave us a tour
of its renovated emergency night shelter
for men filled with new amenities to
help get those on the streets back on
their feet
it's sad to see the people out on the
street for the last six months edward
williams has been calling the streets of
las vegas his home and he's not alone as
of february of this year the census
revealed about 5 600 homeless men and
women in southern nevada it's hard it
really is i mean
once you get to help you've got to find
some place that will accept you and you
know oh i'm homeless well we don't want
you because you're homeless that is
where catholic charities of southern
nevada is stepping in with the renovated
emergency night shelter for men to help
them get off the streets the great thing
about those primary needs that we have
of food and shelter is it allows our
case managers to get in touch with
people and find out where they're at and
then get it get them back to being
sustainable the project has been
underway for the last year and a half
which includes a renovation of their 400
beds phone charging lockers fresh paint
and new plumbing this campus is a little
over 20 years old and as you can imagine
with the thousands of people that we
serve here each and every day that it
gets worn out the 2022 census state 52
percent of the total homeless population
is white and single 51 percent are
unsheltered and over the last seven
years the numbers are rising my wife's
here we were separated i'm trying to get
her back that's one of the reasons i'm
trying to find an apartment for this 62
year old veteran from indiana the
renovated shelter along las vegas
boulevard and owens he says is a
blessing all the homeless really need is
just to know that somebody is out there
that cares for them
well southern nevada has a variety of
resources for our homeless population
from shelters to food assistance now
there are ways that you at home can help
if you see a homeless encampment in your
neighborhood we have that information
available right now on our website
eightnewsnow.com